Banish your fears
while you sleep.
It could be possible.
Here's how.
Hey, this is Annie for D News.
Now, all of us are scared of
something, rational or not--
spiders, snakes, flying,
needles, heights, clowns,
umbrellas.
OK, that last one
might be just me.
But think about it.
They're all pointy, and ugh.
Anyway, according to a new study
from Northwestern University,
the secret to overcoming
fear could lie in your sleep.
We all know it's important
to get a good night's rest.
As we talked about before on
the show, getting enough z's
can improve attention
span, physical and creative
performance, among
many other benefits.
But new research indicates
that sleep can also
play a role in eradicating fear.
Here's how it worked.
The research team
showed adult subjects
a photo of different faces.
But for two of those, they
also received small shocks.
They also smelled a sense for
each photo-- clove, lemon,
mint, et cetera.
And they eventually
learned to fear
the faces that were
associated with the shock,
as measured by sweat
levels and neuroimaging.
Then the subjects went to sleep.
And once they were in the deep
phase known as slow wave sleep,
they were re-exposed to some
of the smells associated
with the pictures
and the shocks.
Well, the researchers found
that after being exposed
to the smells during
sleep, the subjects
had a less fearful
response to those
faces that they
linked with shock.
The study is based
in what's called
exposure therapy for phobias,
where you're gradually
exposed to something until you
become comfortable with it,
starting with say, a
picture of a spider,
then slowly working your way
up to actually holding one.
And in this case,
the exposure happened
during the phase of
sleep that is believed
to play a role in memory
consolidation, where
the memories you accumulate
throughout the day
are solidified.
Now, granted, the fears in
the were engineered, unlike,
for example, that
intense fear of clowns
you've had ever since that
first grade slumber party,
where you watched
It that one time.
But the researchers are
hopeful that down the road,
sleep could be used to treat
existing phobias or even
conditions like PTSD that
deal with traumatic memories--
pretty cool.
So do you have any phobias?
Let us know in the comments.
I already told you my
weird umbrella thing,
so now you have
to tell me yours.
Till then, thanks
for watching D News,
and I'll see you next time.